sometimes we have secret conversations
before well yeah you don't want to hear
that no stuff no no you won't do that
it's not helpful you said friends 19
times too so yeah yeah hey bro you were
playing the guitar and i thought i would
uh i was going to try to improvise a
song with you you're just learning
another another alt-right song
yeah yeah
you really want me to write songs well
you want me to grab it
if i see it into the ball's head
you want to grab it can't say that
do you have a song in your head
no i was he was just going he was doing
the same
dude well that's my towel i was playing
with talaga oh chin was teaching me
chin can play metal yeah chimp yeah chin
knows a lot of them i don't know if he
could play that on air we get kicked off
you can't even fake it i think that's a
good point i don't know i think you can
i think you can play live
you can't we got kicked off youtube uh
where chappelle was just wrapping lyrics
and they demonetized wow
really they can't just [ __ ]
because you're you're not a rapper so if
you're doing something live yeah that's
true because it's being recorded you can
do anything live if you if you have a
black box you can like cover songs do
anything you want and you don't have to
pay yeah uh but it's weird because like
i'll see like
people doing cover songs like like like
a guitar cover of this band and they'll
have the band's music playing but
they're not it doesn't matter they're
they're not making money off that no
they're not yeah so oh it's old it's
only they do monetize it if you're
like you know homeboy uh
the full send boys the steve will do it
yeah he posted this thing of his uh do
you know who he is i don't know i just
went yeah but he was like for the story
let's say a jagillion subscribers okay
he makes more money than anybody we know
on youtube and he has like 30 million
subscribers he posted the other day he
was i only made three grand off youtube
and all last year because then all his
videos would put like drake music or big
sean or just like major music yeah he's
thinking they demonetize that so he's
like so should i stop doing that to make
money or she's making so much money
elsewhere healing you'll [ __ ] yeah
that's how a lot of the big vloggers do
it they'll take a hit youtube wise and
they get sponsors to cover they're not
that smart
so they just make it to where you can't
make money but like your views like wait
wait so so if you have so if you do a
music video i mean if you do a video
like that and you have drake on it yeah
you can't make money off the video but
you can get sponsors for the video yeah
yeah so like if we sang all the drake
songs on here and played his music but
then we have yeah our own sponsor on
there you can make money off oh okay
you're just not making anything off the
youtube algorithm okay but you're still
piggybacking off of you know
it still makes your videos lit remember
do you guys know who david dobrik is
he's yeah he used to be a huge vlogger
he still is uh he actually came out and
said that yes he did yeah uh he came out
and said that what he would do is put uh
mainstream music on his vlogs to create
a vibe that people will [ __ ] with and
people will watch that and then have his
sponsors like live nation then cover the
cost of what he would have lost
and that's how he made a lot of the
money yeah because a lot of people [ __ ]
with how his videos are made and the
like general vibe that he creates within
it by putting smart like relevant music
in it and so with his fan base it then
gets him a lot of views even though he
doesn't make money off the views he's
making money from his sponsor and he has
huge sponsorship i would use like drake
and stuff to promote my shows on
instagram you're fine i can pull it down
but twitter will
like they're like two years lag where's
sony like hey we're claiming the rights
to this if you do it again we're going
to ban your profile
so i'll have chris or somebody go
through and delete those because you
don't need them have them delete all the
old ones huh because by the time they
get to them they're off oh wow yeah oh
that's cool you can't put any song on
twitter no damn i mean he can for a
while but but then after yeah like
they'll be like you know you violated
the rules and whatever there's from like
videos from like three years ago yeah
they claim them
it's more like sony and [ __ ] but that's
interesting you know i actually made a i
recreated an entire band or we had a
whole band all the bass drums singing
all that stuff we created a song we got
demonetized already so we actually made
the entire song but since it's a song
that already exists it's the exact same
song but we you know we did it
differently doesn't matter
we recreated a nirvana song or something
oh god i thought it was like an original
day no no you guys so when you're a
musician now or do most musicians make
it online first
or do they sound good
so you don't go to you don't go to
traditional
something some do some some can't get
discovered but like i mean the online
world has like helped out musicians like
yeah
youtube
talk is here
yeah dozia started on tick tock uh
actually dojo started on youtube she
popped off on uh tick tock because a lot
of the dance challenges got it did you
heard anything that blew up was on the
cow video oh that was on youtube a few
years ago
uh [ __ ] i'm a cow that's doggie cat's
like first main stream because i'm a cow
yeah it's her in like a sexy cow she's
thick
she was thick back then now she's
definitely you look at him and be like
oh that's a cow
she's hot she's super nice
she's bad as hell
that's [ __ ] gonna mute it just in
case
if you guys want to watch it [ __ ] i'm a
cow yeah [ __ ] i'm a cow
[Laughter]
yeah it was huge it's hilarious she
recorded it and then created like a imac
music video 97 million and this was
three three years ago
super hot yeah
she is the biggest artist right now yeah
she's the most streaming artist on spot
wow
and she blood and stuff yeah she is
black and jewish black and jewish okay
her mom's white her dad's black
yeah she's super jesus christ oh
jesus yeah
now she's like the most famous artist on
the and she just made that and then boom
yeah that's crazy
bieber got discovered off youtube yeah
he was originally a youtuber usher
founder oh [ __ ]
too right
uh myspace oh my gosh damn
yeah yeah so it sounds like she's just
saying [ __ ] i'm a coworker
oh it's a terrible song oh well like
there are funny verses it's more like a
joke song it wasn't really anything to
really launch her career she's just
she's a troll she's an internet troll
wow
yeah because she likes streams does she
still troll yeah she does she's still on
yeah she does a lot of instagram live
videos where she trolls people she'll
play video games and she's on her twitch
basically just really yeah she plays
like that's [ __ ] amazing that r red
dead gamer other [ __ ] it is i'm writing
oh uh right now the shooting game yeah
ooh yeah she's super bad
her team was like hey you need to lose a
little weight and she said say less and
then she blew up
but she wanted me to lose weight
i appreciate the way she was looking
before yeah
good never mad at her lord have mercy
yeah she used
the biggest thing going on okay well she
doesn't miss i get it yeah
i mean that's she'll just troll
[ __ ] she wizz yeah she's super
she whizz america what the [ __ ] is going
on you know she's from the valley
she is yeah oh she's from here yeah yeah
she's at la loca well all hail to the
valley dated
or something
i don't know why she got that video of
her i don't think so probably
oh no that was a uh internet meme for a
while people were making fun of omarion
for this performance you're always doing
the dance
wow
[Laughter]
i think that's a great
dance he's just doing the red carpet for
the [ __ ] of it
no i think this was a performance
somewhere and this just happened to be
his choreographer oh wow
didn't seem like he put much time into
it
he's a badass dancer
he said [ __ ] it let me just hit this
real quick that's the guy where uh his
the guy that was in his group uh yeah
his girl mama yeah there's baby mama and
then they're supposed to go on tour with
each other but yeah and then omarion
said nope yeah he booted him off the
tour or something like that uh it was
supposed to be omarion and b2k and then
omarion then said you know what i'm just
going to go on this tour by myself no
more b2k remember when rap was on last
week uh we played that uh clip of uh um
joe budden saying he's bisexual oh yeah
yeah you know that was edited he never
said that he was reading a comment on
the baby's profile god damn it and so
people edited to make it seem like he
came out as gay that's why i didn't
trust it mother is that crazy yeah what
the goddess yeah but uh so the baby did
say that to get out of his house no no
no no no he was ready
like you know he went to the page and
there's a comment oh yeah and he was
really how do i say this he was like
reading the comment
and people edited it and made it look
like you just came out of this game
such an [ __ ] well that's what
charlemagne on brexit because they came
out and said this is not the case at all
man and they're like you yeah you guys
celebrate this like wait till they start
going through your stuff your comments
no [ __ ] editing it to make you look like
an [ __ ] yeah yeah so i did it yeah
yeah and i didn't know at all i don't
know yeah i couldn't trust it because i
was like i need more content it's a
larger thing
that deep fake [ __ ] yeah
that guy who looks like tom cruise if
you've seen that so good yeah we saw it
unbelievable
remember
i showed you that i know
i'd seen it before i was not right no
because i was talking about the other
time yeah that we did your spots cleared
up yeah my spots clicked
all of this is scab and that wants it
how many did you get more than you got
three going what are they melted off for
three months they freeze it off oh like
a like you would for like a wart yeah
yeah they just it's just that all it is
is a sunspot where the
where i guess these the one on your nose
healed fast and the others are kind of
yeah yeah yeah you guys
they are healed they that i just kept
that oh i kept picking it like tomorrow
it'll be gone yeah i don't notice it
yeah
so i'll look young dalia said you had
[ __ ] on your nose from uh
sucking fighters [ __ ]
and then brought my kleenex and he kept
giving me clean access
because you have [ __ ] on your nose from
kids muscles
that guy is always [ __ ] funny so
funny
that was 100 at the time it was a good
time oh yeah oh yeah never mind we left
so hard yeah and then and then at one
point
i love stupid [ __ ] i just i'll never get
tired of dumb [ __ ] and at the end mike
had the camera on me he said brian
uh give us your recap of the night and
brennan's behind me sitting down i'm
like on my phone
i'm catching up on my phone yeah and i'm
feeling nostalgic i'm feeling like i'm
feeling so good yeah and and i'm feeling
like you're serious you're reflecting a
little bit let's go on on a great time
with your friends right yeah because to
me that's kind of all that matters you
know yeah so i go i'm about to just talk
about it
i go you measure your life because you
know what mike you measure your life one
laugh at a time and all of a sudden i
just hear i go you measure your life
just you know kind of one level i just
hear behind me in the loudest voice
and like to the point he may as well
push me where you know you get pushed in
the back and your head goes yeah and you
get whipped last night yeah well you're
like ah what the [ __ ] i'm singing a song
i started laughing so hard oh my god you
just ruined the entire vibe you ruined
everything you were dead serious too
damn serious
it just ruined the whole jesus christ
dude i was like what are you doing hey
yo i did something what i watched the
whole main card oh nice i don't think
i've done that would you watch that i'm
a boy toby's house that'd be a that'd be
the card brutal yeah it was good yeah
brutal what yeah that fight between
between oh that was a great card my big
part of the year
that's a good one to watch i was i was
kind of bummed i missed the plant in
canelo though i couldn't find a way to
get both of those
someone could have sent you over you
know you know did you see that plant was
talking to the canelo the plant was
going pretty good got good skills you
can all that goes yeah i know how weird
is that it was like the 10th ranking
goes i'm pretty good though yeah i'm
doing well yeah and canola was yeah he's
like come on
knocks him out the next round hey you
know what gave me chills
when uh
oozman and covington like yep yeah
that's how it usually goes yeah yeah
yeah i didn't think so last time
uh he kind of stormed off we finished
him last time he got he got stopped oh
god yeah so he's pissed yeah but usually
yeah all the [ __ ] time oh really even
with colby yeah he's a good dude yeah
well i met him that one time with you oh
in miami in miami that's right he's
really nice yeah he's great dude uh you
know who came to my show on thursday
stopped by to check out the set with
schultzy uh andrew schultz yeah schulte
came by the haha that's great how's he
doing he's uh
he's shooting something i don't think i
can talk about he's shooting something
um so then he came
wait let me see this
ryan stole my beanie
b let's take a little break from the pod
because i'm starving grubhub
oh yeah that's what i'm talking about
grubhub okay look if you want
delivered food delivered fast fresh and
exactly how restaurants intended to be
okay well guess what grubhub works for
you perfect man and i love panera so
grubhub is doing a little special thing
with panera all right today grubhub is
doing something real special
for panera get free delivery perk on
your first order from panera of 15 or
more order through the grubhub app or
online grubhub we serve restaurants
you said let me tell you something dude
for me it's about working out it's about
eating i work on the inside i meditate
it's all about the inside of my face
it's like trash well i tend to not have
a skin regimen and you know what i'm a
guy i don't feel like they have anything
for guys i mean when you primp and you
work on the inside of your body i guess
you're supposed to work on the outside
like your skin it only covers all your
body you don't do you want to what do i
do do you want to eliminate those nuts
under your eyes yes your skin dry like a
lizard i just want smooth beautiful skin
dude i'm getting older got razor burns
all right i like the way your skin looks
like my friends at disco help you out
disco yeah man disco is a clean skincare
brand based in austin texas really are
they made for they're all made for skin
issues like under eye bags
acne or all oily
does it have stuff for wrinkles yes
disco got you covered man disco products
are easy to use they're effective
affordable they take the guesswork out
of taking care of your
skin right are they formulated by an ivy
league
dermatologist
put this together man so if you're
looking to take care of your skin for
the first time let disco starter kit set
you off man it's a no-brainer the
starter set is incredibly simple and
convenient way to upgrade your
appearance of your skin in three simple
steps take 60 seconds a day we had a
face cleanser one right we got a face
scrub and we got a hydrating face
moisturizer which i think you need most
i really do for my wrinkles come on yeah
dude it's tsa approved and very portable
so we got you covered so if you want to
check out disco and try their incredible
skin care products for yourself we got a
little gift for you firing the kid
audience viewers and listeners go to
let's disco dot com slash fighter or
enter fighter at checkout for 30 off the
best skin product for the bros let's
disco.com
fighter for 30 off your first order
thank you disco
i look so and feel so young
i'm gonna start wearing a medium
okay i won't you know what you know me
dude someone put rumor has it josh still
hung over from us
he was happy oh no oh that's you right
now i miss her so much look at him
ocean avenue
what jedi
maybe i'm missing the fight maybe i'm
missing the fight i i've got i got rules
up i can be honest i don't know what's
happening
brendan what's the [ __ ] thing that
your hair was unbelievable i don't know
what's happening that rose up two to one
that's terrible
yeah that's what you look like you're a
bummer
you got that down to be a great fighter
he
of my cheeks nails
nails in this club you look sweet i
don't have no manager
i want to be a manager i'm 75 years old
no how much i look something [ __ ] guy
that like is still in acting class in
new york city
and you see him at the gym and you're
just like oh for [ __ ] sake it's this
guy this guy yeah i've been doing a lot
of black boxing you know what you're
dreaming i made it after 50 years yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm gonna start using young terms like
that actually poor josh though flies
round trip from dublin didn't eat didn't
eat lands showers rushes over to the
studio
we put whiskey in his face i mean he
asked for it yeah and then so he got
drunk off like half a [ __ ]
shot yeah he get the hammer oh yeah he
came in from dublin yeah i mean he had
no sleep he wasn't eating any he been
also trying to hang he's trying to hang
with three comedians yeah
you know but he's great i was telling
you it felt like when you know when you
you make new friends in college and then
your friends from high school come
around you got to try to make get them
into the mix yeah and you're like trying
to like be the middle man like
you played soccer in high school right
so did ryan you know yeah that's how i
was that's that's because because that
that i'm because we all have a language
i'm the middle man yeah you're the
middle man yeah but we all but we have a
language we've been talking a long time
and josh that's a different life like
when we're talking about your nuts he
was like what is what
and the chin just goes just let him go
man
yeah how are your shows at brea great
great yeah i love these crowds are great
right
love that damn club yeah it was really
cool
i love that that club and i love that
area they just
that's where a lot of our fan base is so
i think orange county's great they're
doing it right your boy knew some m.i.a
newsome might be you know he got the
boost he had the booster shot hasn't
been seen since yeah he's sick
and he doesn't want to show it because
it's gonna you know if that comes out
that he got definitely the optics are
better yeah i know he's just missing
yeah i know people that took that
booster and it put them on their ass
yeah
yeah
thanks for the example bro and then his
wife and then his wife is like do you
ever think maybe as a life it's just not
politics and he's at sporting events
that got taken down in three seconds
he's like hey [ __ ] what are you doing
go ahead and take that down
that literally got taken down oh they
took it down what she said oh my god
yeah she took it down really yeah he was
like what are you doing
yeah
yeah because it's not like you just
messed up he has a life outside of
politics it's not like you just missed
like some random meeting you missed big
deal [ __ ] yeah it's weird
the longest we haven't seen him
wow yeah down for the count yep and we
just don't know yeah we know you know i
mean why else would you just be missing
just missing i know
this is not a surprising or a new thing
it's not surprising to hear this but i
know people that know him pretty damn
well yeah i spent time with him way
before he was a governor and uh one of
the things they'd always say is that
when he was hanging out with the boys
he's one of the boys oh really yeah and
he's he gets down he's he's a very
different person it's dr jekyll mr hyde
like when he puts his jacket on he's
politicians most people are literally
yeah
you couldn't be that you couldn't be the
one of the boys and run for [ __ ]
government well
sure yes
i think desantis is pretty much probably
who he is in general uh not i'm not a
fan but i don't think trump i think was
probably pretty similar yeah yeah i i
just think that is
him i think he just puts on when i see
him he's such a politician it's so fake
and i'm looking at that that's the same
problem with kamala harris that's why
she no one [ __ ] with it on either side
left all right everyone's like it just
seems too fake she's awesome like when
she tries
yeah she's just like when she tried uh
you know getting the the the black vote
and then you see her see her in like
tim's like you know what what are you
doing yeah and they were the wrong teams
that they don't wear in new york
it sounds like hey put these on people
like this
but you see through all that you just
see oh you smell it my mother my mother
would always say you know you're you
we'd learned to communicate long before
we we developed language
uh you know the homo sapiens and whether
you know it or not you pick up on body
language facial expressions what the
eyes are saying your mouth might be
smiling but if your eyes ain't smiling
we can that's creepy yeah and and we
also know when you're being
condescending we know when you like
somebody for real when you don't like
somebody yeah you know what my my issue
is
say something to me recently who who
makes his living by being able to read
people because they have to loan them a
billion dollars or whatever it wouldn't
be and he said um he said your issue is
that
because you like people so much and i do
i like people and you told me that yeah
i just like people you said that i see
the best part i see the best part of
them i don't i never i ignore them
and and he said my buddy said the
problem with you dude is that
because you like people they see that
and a lot of times they show you their
best side yeah you never see the real
you're not seeing the real side you're
seeing their best side
and then what happens is the other
people that i know who are discerning go
why are you bringing that guy around
he's a dick yeah
like the entire time we've known each
other what is what is it you just like
you just simply he likes people no
you just i think i like people and you
want them to like you so brian put you
know well my might have been the best of
my theory but my theory is having moved
around been moved around so much as a
kid people say why are you a comic okay
well what do i do okay so i'm [ __ ]
throw me in a different country
different continent different language
different school every year and a half
as a kid yeah so you you want to make
friends you want to make friends what do
you do learn how to be not be the last
guy picked on on the team be okay at
sports but also [ __ ] learn very
quickly
how to read people what are people what
are people proud of and what are they
ashamed of that my philosophy is
everybody is ashamed of a certain aspect
of their life and proud of another
accentuate the proud protect them from
what they're ashamed of
you know if i were teaching a course on
how to manipulate people or how to but
for me it was natural like for me i
didn't want i hated seeing anybody
embarrassed i hate seeing as you know i
can't stand seeing people's feelings get
hurt or be embarrassed
oh and so i and rogan would always
criticize me on this because i just
can't stand it so what i do who is that
time the way you're a middleman like
wait i was always the middleman i was
always trying to take people under your
wing always always yeah because i i want
people to be the their their best selves
it doesn't mean i'm more virtuous it's
just a personality trait i probably
can't help it i developed i don't think
it was surprising you could turn it off
if you wanted right it was survival for
me though as a kid i had that that was
the only way i was going to make friends
quickly
and you don't feel like you lose out on
anything by being this way i think you
get burned a i think you waste a lot of
time on people that means
you know that you're not just a waste of
time because most he's not getting the
real people true that's how you bring
crazy and broken in but that was like
a ton of times i did it with the women
you still you stay nice like you you
stay it doesn't mean it doesn't get
burned yeah yeah i know but most people
like when they do get burned a lot
they're probably just you know very
standoffish and well that wow but like
you you seem to continue someone says
stay genuine yeah some say not learning
your lesson no
well yes
no but that's a good point like so so
how do you balance the larger question
is this so just take this year this past
year yeah a lot of times when you go
through a disaster you're very
disappointed by human humanity and
people it's just the contract you've
entered into gets mocked and shredded
right you just like you it's a different
place you're like oh this is the way the
game's playing you know you you would
say i've spent a lot of my life trying
to do good things for people yeah you
know that's stuff going to happen
private charities you know private
charities um uh doing what i can and i
think what happens is you can get very
cynical
you can get cynical and you can lose
your generosity lose your optimism but
then if i do that then then then the
dark side wins
i don't want that to happen i don't want
that to have power of me i don't want to
change
i don't want to change yeah i i need to
be i need to no i need to go i need to
be a little more discerning you don't
see me boundaries more yeah and don't
bring people don't bring people in who
are not worth it because if you bring
people in that are not worth it you
don't have energy for the people that
are worth it yep so you gotta be more
discriminating
right that might help you're good at
that but i've never been good at that
and you're you know you're you're a
middle i mean rogan is the best i've
ever seen it literally i'm between rogan
and bruh yes okay logan's the best yep
i'm all i'm in the middle yeah and then
brian's over here yeah because i feel
like yeah you don't just say yes to like
anything no but he's also soft he's a
softy yeah yeah
he what's your name but you but you you
you seem like you correct me if i'm
wrong but you seem like you dig more
into
finding out like just to make sure like
if you're gonna brian's gonna trust you
right away i don't trust you right got
it you gotta earn it yeah and even if
you [ __ ] me over i'm gonna be like i had
a bad day
like it wasn't i mean i i mean it's my i
don't know that's not a good thing i
know it's not i know it's not a good
thing but like it's a weird thing i have
i don't know yeah and and i probably
will never change it look good and bad
you're 54. yeah yeah yeah what are you
good with i'd rather be i'd rather be
i'd rather be that would be like that
than that i'd rather be really nice to
it i'd rather do that you'd rather be
[ __ ]
i'm less important i don't know but
rogan is is
the really successful people i know a
lot of times are really good at getting
rid of you know that pareto's principle
you ever heard that when you have a
company twenty percent of your people
are are responsible for eighty percent
of your profits and twenty percent of
your people are responsible for eighty
percent of your problems so so you know
and and sometimes it's it's three
percent of the people are responsible
for 90 of your problems cut those
[ __ ] out yeah he's good at that
and he can just go like this ah done
yeah immediately jesus christ dude he's
like nah and he could reach but there's
a reason for it because he'll take your
energy and he's great well he's also
good at his survival was having to see
who wasn't
uh pure in their intentions yeah he grew
up especially now he grew up alone in a
lot of ways yeah so that [ __ ]
that's i was kind of shocked that he
because he approached me when i first
met him and i was kind of shocked but he
thought he had met me or something well
because you you are
somebody i was pretty cool i was staying
quiet but you're worth it chappelle i
saw you immediately what i say to you
the first time i saw you i went come to
l.a because i saw something special you
know how many guys you still come to l.a
very three one thousand three
no three one thousand literally three
people you know
houston no
no i almost i felt it was genuine when
you said that i really when people say i
want to get into stand-up and stuff like
i've never
you if you if you say brian i want to be
an actor or a comic
9 900 times out of a thousand i'm going
to say do not do that yeah but there are
like i probably said three times one of
the things i remember you said to me
that night and i remember that night
clearly you were like you're like are
you reading and when i thought about
that i was like oh am i reading i'm not
reading then i just started like
yes reading you know just uh i'll look
at you because i knew you were smart i
knew you were [ __ ] smart
you know
it informs your your expression
i think it's it's important
uh no one in here watch yellowstone last
night two hour premiere no no one's in
the yellowstone i am i just bro it's
season
four
and you know how like it's it took a
while to come out and people fans were
complaining
bro did it deliver did it it was so
intense really oh so [ __ ] good did
anybody see the harder they fall
with idris alba it's a black western on
netflix no
[ __ ] pretty damn good
fun
zazzy beats all these great actors is it
based off a true story no man now what
city in the west was all black
background
that's the whole point that is
what was so funny and good about it he's
[ __ ] he's ruthless
who is oh and that dude on the right i
don't know who that actor is but he's
phenomenal i forget it lake regina king
yeah
he's from get out i love that guy yeah
he's great he's in his otl too yeah and
lynn oh yeah so good oh
yeah yeah that was a good movie
i thought so i loved it i thought it was
really really entertaining really
yeah very good like
tarantino or something
oh it is a true story wow
oh now you guys dress more like
[ __ ]
i guess les western on the right and
more mexican well probably native
americans so there was a lot of native
american
like slaves who would run away sometimes
would go to
you know oh there goes no the story yeah
no it's not it's not based on true there
are a lot of native american tribes that
have a lot of black in them like in when
we were in were you with me when when i
think it was cherokee nation or wherever
where was it no it might have been um
upstate yeah remember no i think it was
upstate sacramento remember and then oh
and the tribe was all essentially bla
bla i was like well they look pretty
african-american to me really i don't
know where were we all that dude look at
that
yeah maybe i was pretty native american
to me look up the caloosa look at the
casino oh no the the picture metabolism
was unbelievable
tribe maybe yeah yeah because that'd be
close there was a picture of it and
but you have to go to the lucid casino
that the picture was like i was like
well
interesting you'll see
inclusive casino pictures i think that's
what it was i don't they they look so
indian to me no dude i they are but
there is the picture of the tribe of the
elders or who own the tribe i was like
not resort photos that's gonna be
pictures of the casino you know i know
but i'm not sure what you guys are
looking for right now was that a was
that a good game i think
uh
sure yeah it's a casino you know yeah
well because i've done one yeah and it
was it was
tough
well we've we've done a few casinos did
calusa who did that oklahoma okay maybe
it's not closest sorry guys no they look
straight in there he is oh yeah that guy
looks black not
well that's
yeah
could have been oklahoma brian maybe it
was oklahoma oh they were super indian
oklahoma they were very they're very
very indian maybe we were talking when
you do that casino in uh jamaica might
have been in jamaica might have been in
jamaica i think it was in that very
black part oh that's great oh it's when
you did that casino in south africa
yeah that was not like the casino yeah
but it was the american indian
native yeah and that's probably africa
that's right these native americans are
black
that makes sense well they're rather
black
i took a [ __ ] uh spin class the other
day those are tough huh that uh party on
or it's not a part called party on a
bike that's back home was the music
blaring yeah blair ready and it's all
yeah it's still dark bro you know yes
did it make you wear a mask no that's
good no he was getting down
uh you know what made it like tough and
i think i didn't think i thought i'd try
to keep up with other people that and uh
because i haven't done it in like
forever but uh they they brought out
these like little weights those little
10-pound little oh and you're on the
bike doing it yeah you have to like and
i'm like and i didn't think i was going
to start peloton style oh my god it was
tough
but i liked it did you do it in the
valley no where'd we do it uh marina del
rey that's when i did it was with bert i
haven't done it in a while they're good
they're good i'd rather do something
else about it no you know not my thing i
like the vibe i like the internet smells
like a fart in there yeah i don't like
the music it's true you like the music
the music is so intense reminds me of
cheerleading yeah that makes sense yeah
yeah that's why the music is all your
heart rate and [ __ ] yeah yeah
the best workouts i've ever had are the
ones that on it jim pushing a sled and
stuff like that about sweat city oh
i like that on the job doctor
yeah those workouts are that was fun
like half hour in and out if i had that
every day that would be great oh that
was [ __ ] i like that damn skier
but pushing a sled might be the best
thing for your legs oh yeah we had that
don't they have that dope sled we like
where you can just well you could adjust
yeah the weight yeah resistance i think
that's the i think that's yeah i wish we
had an on it out here
sorry look at that it's literally it's
only location yeah yeah best-looking
people you'll ever see
men and women yeah
i remember i was wearing i've never felt
shittier about myself when i when those
[ __ ] pro football players were all
working out with their shirts off like
right next to us remember where i was
like one more person tells me i'm a pro
athlete yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna i'm
gonna
feel that i'm not lost
one more person ask me if i'm a pro
athlete i'm gonna these guys jack i felt
like such a piece of [ __ ] like you need
to go to the zoo the guys in there like
really those guys those guys are
bodybuilders these guys are dude
they're just jacked well they're all
like influencers or bodies oh jesus like
they're all like i don't give a [ __ ]
about those guys when i'm around these
boys
giants yeah middle linebackers and
they're just shirts are off they got
long hair and i'm like how the [ __ ] what
happened
yeah god you even you get insecure
around like both of us are like look at
their they take their shirts off and
you're like
to take your shirt off at zoo though
those boys are just yeah i would never
see a lot of guys with their shirts
oh meatball dude i did yeah you did he
took his shirt off well because i only
had a long sleeve so i wasn't gonna like
i was wearing a long sleeve in
sweatpants i wasn't gonna work out and
that's why i didn't
show up for them girls though dude i
have a chest of a 10 year old i ain't
showing off to anybody you got to let
yourself go the greatest took some balls
to take your shirt off the zoo if your
torso is american you got it it's got to
be free that's what i say you taking
your shirt off as zoo as like a girl
with zero tits working on hooters yeah
it's just you gotta you gotta attack
he's got some tits he doesn't have a
terrible chest
he's got shoulders i'll show him whose
is bigger whose chest is bigger yours
are counting definitely talent oh he
doesn't have no
has never had an incline bench in his
life
meatball really going to take his shirt
off he don't give a [ __ ]
that's not a bad body dude i have a bad
body though
i see what you're saying about the chest
but my arms like my arms
that's the only reason why i was okay
with it yeah do you hit dumbbells and
[ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah he works his ass off in there
you're in there mm-hmm
every day
yeah every day in zoo
oh [ __ ] i either go to zoo or or i go to
gold's in glendale hey hey you was
boxing yesterday i saw you hitting the
what did they call that bag uh it was it
was kind of like a
it wasn't like the water bag but it was
uh like a low it
usually three times a week yeah how long
of a drive is it for me yeah i mean i'm
off wilshire and like so is it 30
minutes for you yeah where is two it's
it's eight minutes from my house if that
yeah i'm right up there and so so but
that's an hour for you guys you just
have not at heavier uh no it's like 30
minutes 30 minutes that's it no i'm
saying oh they're working out
45 what are you going to do to that kid
that's actually good that's what's like
what's your punching dude what like a
droplet bag
is that your hands are good dude that's
that
holds nice jab yeah see how's the talent
that grows i don't care about your
boxing how's it telling that gold like
women
yeah
good are they good oh goodbye yeah i
don't know look i fall in love at least
like three times of course you do it's
like what the [ __ ]
yeah i fall in love three times a day
it makes sense yeah
way hotter than the ones at zoo
guaranteed what time do you be at benzoo
when it's popping like three four
o'clock in the afternoon yeah when the
tick tockers sleep in come up come out
from underneath their cages freaks come
out now yeah but like there's there's
just
a zoo there's not that many of them like
there's like maybe like 10 15.
like but when they come yeah they hold
every five minutes a bad girl comes in
i'm like oh you're not meeting anybody
huh i mean like i don't want to be that
guy like to go up to a girl and hit on
him during a workout i'm not that type
of guy respect yeah you could dm one
though later
oh no i've
been trying to do good stuff not working
like the way you squat saw you on the
bench
i just like it kind of weirds me out a
little bit i don't want them to think it
is it is
it is awkward yeah they say it's a no-no
that's what they say at the gym
they say it's a no no to do that what'd
you do this weekend [ __ ]
i made your fight can pay him with us
yeah
and then just hung out with my girl and
then he came to the what do you call my
show friday friday went to your show
yeah you weren't yeah it was dope that's
right yeah
dope that's right good crowds
real good girls that's great yeah yeah
in that outside area no never
no i refused it was it shows the huh
yeah that's where they were holding it
yeah they had it for a while i've done
four shows out there
not this year
outside where you did the meet and greet
that's what you started i'm talking
about two [ __ ] months ago i was doing
shows they were holding a headline there
four times this year well the one
everything's indoor bubble no they they
do have uh
where i do the mean group yeah
yeah yeah yeah not that outdoors yeah
well it was good those outdoor shows
were show shows they were good shows
these are small there uh well it wasn't
that small they got they packed that
whole i'm talking about the that that no
i know i do my meet and greet there yeah
yeah they had a lot they they packed
that in it was pretty packed yeah it's
not like the main room there
it's just as big dude
no italian i've been i'm
i've been there four times i've done
that show i've been doing that that club
for 10 years and that's fine you want to
you want bet i'll bet you a thousand
dollars that outdoor venue doesn't seat
as many as the indoors well i mean it i
mean i don't know the numbers but it was
pretty packed there was no i'm sure i'm
well it wasn't really so much outdoor i
mean it's just you did it recently
yeah well i mean i don't know probably
during the pandemic yeah three months
ago no not three more than that yeah
because they've been open for a while
whenever they yeah because that's the
only reason i go to the club because
they're they're open and you know they
have full capacity right right right
because they do they [ __ ] yeah dude the
other ones aren't no the another one you
know it's dicey so you're talking about
the round
i'm talking the full rooms wide open
dude that's why i run shows that
it's a good room too
if they pack it that's a good run yeah
great that last show the last night
unreal unreal unreal yeah that's how a
comedy club should be
that they surround you like that's cool
because it's always been struggling but
i'm glad it's like i'm glad it's doing
well yeah i love that family they're
great people man yeah the sun yeah
jack junior yeah
great the mom was there though yeah uh
terry yeah he just yeah terry
yeah that was the only reason i started
doing that club because no club was like
full capacity it's close
super easy yeah 20 minute drive if
that's right with no traffic it's like
15 minutes [ __ ] it's actually it's
not even uh too far from my crib either
no it's it's it's an easy drive yeah
it's easier than me going to hollywood
that club deserves it i'm glad that you
know your support is fun yeah it's a
good club we had a good weekend
yeah yeah shows
came by did his spot yeah chelsea pulled
up all right jim what do you got buddy
all right first one
i'm sorry but if you're gonna do outdoor
shows there's like jam in the van what
else there's that one supernova
supernova those are great yeah yeah i
just haven't the van's got a dope spot
now i like jam in the back the new the
new their
that's the move newest
you don't like outdoor i don't like
outdoor shows yeah i mean i i'm not
saying can you do one in san antonio
yeah well it's tough i just i i i just
prefer the clown yeah because it's like
the sound the sound
some people love it not me at all yeah i
weigh it but i mean if i have to do it i
get it yeah if i have if you give me a
choice i'd rather yeah i would prefer
inside that's what comedy
i've had the only times i've had really
bad sets
like when i was asked to do outdoor like
like you're right you're in some [ __ ]
airplane hangar with no i did one of
those
in santa monica
orange county
but you can't even like you get like the
sound goes into the ether so you don't
like people
listen prescription drugs dude what they
are they're so expensive very expensive
so expensive thank god for good rx yep
80
of people have insurance and still use
good rx when they need to fill
prescription okay why because even with
insurance there's a really good chance
good rx will beat your copay price go to
good rx you can instantly compare prices
for your prescription pharmacies in your
neighborhood and save up to eighty
percent eighty percent yeah and checking
good rx is free and easy it takes a few
seconds to find discounts on your
prescriptions at over seventy thousand
pharmacies cvs kroger walgreens rite
aids vons walmart so much more all right
you can check the website you can also
use goodrx app which is the number one
most downloaded medical app all right
millions of americans are getting on it
for affordable health care every month
so for simple smart savings on your
prescriptions check goodrx go to
goodrx.com
fighter that is good rx.com fighter
goodrx.com fighter rx is not insurance
but can be used instead of insurance in
2020 good rx user saving average of 79
off retail prices
rockauto.coms prices are
reliably low yes for the lowest prices
possible rather than changing prices
based on what the market will bear like
airlines do rocket rockauto.com
is for everybody and does not require
membership or
account login amazing yes so whatever
whip you got i bet rockauto.com can help
you guys out check all the parts
available for your car or truck yo whip
right fighter in their how did you hear
about us box so they know we sent you
amazing selection low prices all the
parts your car will ever need
rockauto.com
i already got you different breed all
right this is sad uh this is super sad
on friday it was the first day of astro
fest which is
travis scott's festival just dedicated
to him and then he has other artists pop
up on it's usually a two-day event on
friday the very first day a bunch of
people had actually bum rushed the vip
entrance so a bunch of people ended up
coming into the concert who didn't have
like tickets or anything but the victim
was 14 16 21 23 and 27 14.
i saw a video someone had their
five-year-old there
that's the thing it's a concert that's
not worth a million years but so many is
travis scott's known like he promotes
like he wants his audience to get crazy
as he said yeah because uh
this time last year there were three
people who were actually trampled during
his concert he had a different concert
where he actually told a guy who was on
the third story balcony to jump and try
to crowd surf he was paralyzed shortly
after that well they were they were
stomping on the the
ambulance were coming through they were
like as well they climbed up to the top
of the ambulance it was
that's on this is also on live nation on
also the absolutely i saw a defense
lawyer talking about and they're like
it's really not on travis scott like he
promotes like his issues he promotes it
that's it because he wants him to get
crazy but he's like he's more on
security and live nation
you know with all the people there right
and then isaac who who works for us he's
been a travis scout concert he's like
dude i've been in the front row it's i
would never do it again because it's
[ __ ] awful jesus christ
because when he comes on he encourages
everybody to get wild and he encourages
people to jump the barricade and do all
this crazy [ __ ] he's like and people are
just getting smashed dude
there can be a worse way to die because
they say you just can't breathe no you
get a it's just a sea of people i'd
rather get shot in the face me too dude
just shoot me in the [ __ ] fat i mean
like and you can't bring your you can't
bring your hands down now you're like
getting you know i don't know what
happened like what goes on there because
i go to a lot of concerts especially
like the hardcore punk ones where like
that's i mean that's our world but like
it's it's for us it's just like a
different etiquette but is it 50 000
people
this is 50 yeah there actually has been
a large trend since then since this has
happened of different people performing
at arena stadiums basically different
artists saying like hey we're being told
that people are getting trampled people
are getting squished together everybody
we're stopping the show take one step i
guess travis said i guess travis said
that was like hey yo we need help down
here like this girl's past like he was
saying like we need help
this is what his problem is he like he
encourages like that craziness the
british the british soccer
federation went through this [ __ ] like
where people got one there was i came
around
oh dude and people got crushed they got
crushed against one side of a wall and
they they from that point on they did
all these measures you can't go to a
[ __ ] soccer game if you're part of a
if you're on a 50 000 holy [ __ ]
and there it is all of what is to be 50
000 people ran to the front oh my god
and you know because the
obviously trav scott's the headliner he
brought drake out so kids lost their
[ __ ]
and rushed to the front oh my god
squeezed minutes before you don't even
know what the [ __ ] is happening dude
yeah it's really heartbreaking there's a
lot of video circulating right now about
uh
people in the crowd where people are
screaming for help but then you can't
hear people he can't see though you guys
a lot of people don't realize when those
lights are on oh there's you can't see
that yeah
yeah you can barely see the camera yeah
you're and you're you're like you're not
aware you're just there there you go
scott pauses afterward performance after
seeing the ambulance
yeah you got to stop
damn like i said right when you start
performing his first song i looked at my
boyfriend said we have to get out of
here damn he said i can't we can't i
should remember looking up and passing
out jesus christ
there have been several ins uh several
different news articles that had came
out since this all happening that travis
scott had stopped his concert three
times to try to check what was happening
meanwhile there are a lot of people on
the hate train right now saying that
it's going to happen but should but my
thing like obviously he like wants this
craziness or whatever but at some point
like these people need to take some
responsibility the fans 100 who rushed
the thing like
you can have as much security as you
want in the front
and what can they do if people are being
[ __ ] idiots and rushing to the stage
and the person in front of you is i
can't breathe and you keep [ __ ] well
people get pushed behind them too though
that's the problem is that you you don't
even realize what the [ __ ] is happening
until it's too late it's like a wave
yeah that's exactly what people
described it as like
they would rush in and then like as
people are pushing forward people then
like back up over time
uh like all the haters online like they
need more security there and the
governor or the mayor houston came out
goes
uh astral world travis scott's contours
have more security than the world series
so stop that [ __ ] yeah like that okay
it's a question of how you barricade and
when you have no barriers and people can
just run to the front yeah that's gonna
happen i think that and then obviously
you can't do fifty thousand people you
can you're gonna have to limit the
access which make the price go through
the roof yeah or have seating where they
can't yeah they have some festivals have
it before they have it split yeah like
if you notice if you see certain like
especially the festivals in europe
you'll see like
the crowd is like that's where there's
that's why they don't use barricades
like if you watch like yeah for stuff
like that exactly why you create those
measures so people don't get we've had a
lot of things that happened in the past
i mean yeah again in the soccer ball
he's had it happen before though mm-hmm
he he they're not to this back yeah
for him i think it's just like i'm i'm
here to get people crazy and have fun
obviously naturally but which is christ
man
that is that's on the that's on the
organizers and and how they set up the
infrastructure it's just i would never
go to travis.com i would i love him and
i love his collabs but i would never go
to a concert ever ever because you're
not 20. yeah you know
and trampled i was always afraid jesus
christ i'm always so scared i'm always
on the outside i took the the logan paul
floyd mayweather i was working i'm
looking around i see all of logan's team
and floyd's team i'm like why are they
so close to the ring in my head i'm
thinking oh if someone pops off this is
gonna be a nightmare like there's not
much security my security guard was 400
pounds and not fast so literally i think
during the second round i look they gave
me personal security i go i'm going to
get out of here dude you get the best
scene in the house you i know i have
anxiety i'm gonna watch it from the back
so i went all the way to the back well
we were in we were in philly we'd done a
show and
like in philly and and in like certain
parts of this and boston people get
aggressive and when they're drinking and
i remember you and i were like i
remember you said hey these because
you're from denver and you were like
this [ __ ] philly crowds i was like
they're notorious for being aggressive
we got the [ __ ] boston
same thing we're like let's get the [ __ ]
out i don't get down i don't want to be
near that i don't want to i don't need
to be in the middle of what the [ __ ] and
then uh stab shoot or fight you know
yeah
no no no no no no no no no no
you got a boss they keep using that
lincoln park video where yeah they don't
use yo yo yo yo stop stop stop yeah
they've been using a lot of link and
park videos there's i mean there's tons
of bands that like different videos
though right like like traffic you're
talking young kids probably i mean young
music lincoln park
do you ever see the uh rolling stone
concert yeah when that the hell's angels
in the concert like it'd be kind of lit
to have hell's angels excuse me yeah
they'll kill you if it's not yeah but we
don't play any games well
yeah how cool would that be if we if i
wrote the hell's angel i'm like heckle
my man larry over there
tells angel's mc he's gonna open you up
a little bit he's gonna have something
to say oh dude that's what happened yeah
one morning didn't get shanked that's
what happened when mike said stand up
live he was rolling around with some
goons and they beat the hell out of this
they stopped the dude out right yeah
it's on youtube they yeah they beat that
dude yeah
he was so bloody he didn't go to the
hospital because my boy um
casey currier he uh he was the gm of the
club at the time
and uh
he saw that whole thing go down he was
trying to get the dude he was trying to
tell them to stop fighting it was didn't
jay paul get beat up after he did that
thing to do what happened by floyd's
goons that's what he wanted though
that's different he got beat up they
just gave him a little rough round yeah
yeah oh he did yeah there's nothing
crazy
yeah man what uh jimmy carr you know the
great yeah best comics alive jimmy carr
who's like one of the best roasters of
all time so people heckle him and he has
a whole bit of like he lit this dude was
come on talk and lights this guy up well
people think like oh that's the vibe so
he's at another show and the guy is
interrupting the show and finally jimmy
like he's not playing and he's like dude
shut the [ __ ] like he's not playing the
roast game with him he's like i'm trying
to do my set shut the [ __ ] up the guy
keeps talking and he has a personal
security guard who is i think former
special forces sure and the guy goes i'm
gonna say something he goes oh you are
mate and he goes i promise you you don't
want harry over there to get his hands
moving it was so funny the guy piped
down super fast oh yeah yeah don't [ __ ]
because his boy came out the back and he
pointed at him because you want harry
just get going here because i promise
you you don't want him to get going no
no
yeah yeah john don't let slip the dogs
that's yeah what else you got jen yeah
traffic stuff's tragic man i just saw
this pop up too that he's covering the
funeral costs for all the people that
died oh
yeah yeah i kind of have to though yeah
i mean
but also it sucks man all the way around
although it's terrible speaking of being
squeezed though we just should mention
that michael rapport's ribs are hurting
a lot
because no no but i want it very clear
remember i didn't ask for this he was he
i will say he was talking a lot of [ __ ]
he was following me we're not making
light of anything that happened there
but i'm just saying that's complete
michael decided michael decided to keep
poking
and then i was i will admit that i was
maybe in the hallway going squeeze him
and then i was going the bathroom and
then he he was like let me get you in a
whatever manhattan headlock yeah i said
let's go
and he said i've never been in one of
those and then he did that and then
tried to give up and then tried to give
up and then you said well no it's too
late now look at him
i attacked him yeah there you go there
you go you said your photoshop game is
crazy
how funny is it he i guess you you
dislodged a rib cartilage or something
he's having some trouble but that's what
you get look at his face shoes are
terrible your shoes are terrible you
like those summers oh those are my
favorites but for real like they're
pretty beefy they're terrible shoes
though right though yeah i mean
just generally wouldn't you say
everybody oh i love those you think
those are dope it's not my style there's
these terrible things never
they're they're you know what not well
let's just they're not for anybody i
would never know that's fair i would
never how do you why i don't know i know
i know you're going to stay here let me
talk every time
so you have adidas tennis shoes on yeah
that you've had for how long so what
forever these are
yeah
but those are great and you have
business
hold on you don't get an opinion because
you have peanut butter falcon vans on
eat a dick
he has
hey you need to be checked sometimes i
like those
you know what i bought another pair i
would like that those are a little bit
those are some of my favorite shoes
would take offensive if you weren't 54.
i gotta be honest i mean if someone
younger came at me i'm just i wouldn't
defend myself
look at my shoes you can see my feet
there
your feet are like everybody look you
know
right they're a little bit
they're too much for you they're too
much they're too much i'm just being now
you wear the same thing every day again
i would say
i would take yourself
i know i'm not exactly a fashion icon
and i like what you're wearing here and
i like i like those are all right
these are louder than those i don't know
how those work though really kind of
blend in those don't ever wear those
again you'll see those all the time i'll
tell you what i'll stop wearing those if
you get a
shoe that was made
past 2012. listen if you don't have on
the palace i will never wear those again
and listen let's hold on i will stop
wearing those if you wear any color
besides gray and black
hey hold on i will stop wearing those if
you quit doing stuff to your face and
get a hair transplant how about that
[ __ ] you have fear i'm not i'm not doing
anything in my face
daddy dad what up did you i had to get
yeah
dude doesn't matter still on the record
books all right got your eyes done okay
and now the dots on your face you've got
that's not classic surgery take that
back right now cosmetic no it's not i
had can't pre-cancer you just wanted to
dot off your nose no it was a little but
she goes i want to take that off and
then she went oh you came in there and
asked her to take it off because she
didn't call go hey i've been noticing
pictures like you have dots alone no my
sister said what's that thing go get it
checked out i wanted to actually go she
goes i don't like i i think we should
get it off there of course and then wear
sunblock because you don't and she goes
let me take these off too sure i stopped
right there they were they were sure all
of this is a little [ __ ] you can't
cause it's cosmetic [ __ ] dude she
was take she she froze some of the
things off now you want to bet that's
not your last person badger
i will not get another procedure i don't
really consider that a receiver thank
you [ __ ] guy get off this come here
no [ __ ] you
dude listen to me velcro shoes
i bought another pair that's crazy yeah
you got dice on your socks i love i i
hey bro i [ __ ] with your [ __ ] man it's
lit that shit's lit
the only time i've ever seen velcro
shoes is on love on the spectrum eat a
dick it's the only time i've ever seen
other people that's not true i hate
someone else you've ever seen velcro i
have been playing with the idea of a
hair who nick davis
love on the spectrum
that's your reference that's i was kind
of saying him to help prove your point
thank you sir he has velcro shoes yeah
i'm with him i do have to i do have to
color
larry any other side's gray and black i
gotta do that i'm i'm gonna go i know
you don't see color but no
any color
blue
black
um gray they're universal i know where
all the [ __ ] things it's because i
don't know really how to once i step out
of color but even
once in a while i have some green it'll
be nice it puts me in a good mood i need
some like good blues like some some sky
navy blue a sky blue maybe that'd be fun
yeah like what the color of your your
hat would be cool
you could wear my beanies green blue
what else can i do what where else can i
go what does it look like
sometimes a pizza top
like a like a red but not aggressive
like a real color
i don't care dude whatever you want a
patch just put patches on that'd be fun
just kind of wear different colored
patches well scarves
scarves are good i just
typed in
it's just old i just said older oh i
meant to take a picture for you
christian and kyle i was driving down
ventura there's a store that says five
eight and under and it's just clothes
for short men that's true and yeah it's
awful it's off yeah it's called like uh
it's a weird name but put a clothing
store off ventura five eight and under
sure it wasn't baby gap or something no
dude i'm dead serious it had like small
suits in the front
it should be called short king's fashion
we should you guys need to go there if
you guys need a suit or i got to start
i'm dressing a little bit too much like
there it is jimmy how do you say that
jimmy's
jimmy owls
look at that expansive shop specializing
in short men wow that could be you guys
i i want to go in there and be like you
have nothing for me
see you later i gotta get it
dude
look at that
oh look at the owner
he said man i need a store that fits me
and then they went you know what we're
going to hire the tallest lady in the
world
to make you guys feel shorter we're
going to hire
yeah
yeah he's the owner see made for of
course george costanza shops there dude
isn't this great
yes he does how tall are you guys again
i'm six
and when you thought you were the same
like dalia was the same height as you i
always thought we were the same then he
stood next to you yeah he's six too yeah
you're so much taller i don't know
shoulders like an athlete his nose is
like here well that was what was weird
is your shoulder
is your shoulder his head is big yeah
your shoulder is way higher yeah so his
height is more in his torso yeah your
eyes he's got long legs and his head's
long he doesn't have long legs no he's
more in his torso
he has a really long big head too
long head yeah so he's got a long skull
whereas you're like more proportioned to
what happened kind of your shoulders
were this higher i know i couldn't
believe how much bigger i was i always
thought me and him were the same size
yeah yeah even he was like she's like a
giant to me i know him now yeah
no no he's not that big anyways that's a
store for you guys if you're looking for
i meant to [ __ ] take a picture of it
he just helped me all out
if you guys take suits and stuff i'll
take a little should i have other shirts
and stuff for small people
business can't be popping right
what's that there for for the jimmies i
don't know
if you're a short guy like i would never
go into big and tall i feel like you're
completely you can go to j crew and get
small yeah right
but like there's suits for y'all
everywhere
yeah yeah right now you gotta get them
tailored if you're that small
you can't just go in this like men's
warehouse right yeah but you can go to
like different places in game two
jimmy's needs to step up their goddamn
social media
and welcome to jimmy owls for men five
eight
the world's most complete menswear store
for short men [ __ ] yeah we design and
develop clothing for men five foot five
to five eight and for men under five
five
so just say our collection was
originally designed five eight and under
yeah just say five afterthought of the
scaled down regular size yeah man and
they're forgetting about yeah a regular
size for a man five foot ten doesn't
produce the proper size for man
you should go in there and you should go
in there and i'm gonna go and go do you
have anything you say you're being
discriminatory yeah and they're trying
to cancel yes yeah then they write an
article about it yeah
or like i went here to get fitted for a
shoot and they said they don't like my
time better yet go get some shorts and
put them on anyway and some shoes and
just be like i got it this is good and
then blast walk out and barely able to
walk yeah i just blasted last my dick
out the front yup
what else you got jen all right how do
you know nova not have a short king
section because they have the curvy
fashion over men you know why i like
money
this is probably not a huge market they
could take over that market they could
somehow change
if you promoted it right
short games yeah
but if the brand was associated with
just short guys like no guy wants you
know it's like small dick fashion you
know what i'm saying like no guy wants
well it's not small dick factory but you
know what i'm saying like if you start
small dick faster
no guys gonna be like oh
because it makes people feel like yeah
yeah short king is a good name make sure
you embrace your shortness even harry
sajuda was calling himself a short king
he was yeah sure and that's great listen
this is for branding for the show but i
think in the real world yeah are people
really gonna like do you want like i
wouldn't wear something that said big
king on it yeah i'm like god damn dude
well he should i think i think he i
think the problem is people would go he
shops at short king and then all of a
sudden your nickname would be short
so it'd be like a [ __ ] guy shops are
short hey check out short king over
there and all of a sudden now it becomes
a like just called a regular game yeah
yeah all right fair enough you would
have to rebrand your kings as like short
kings with big dicks that's the only way
it would work anti-talk
call it the anti-tall short man davidson
type of marketing but with shortcake
yeah we're starting from big b l the
letter l
upside down no
this is the l this is upside down
see what i mean
tall guy yeah you have to make it hot
tall guy
short guy
oh there it is tall guy yeah short guy i
like that i don't i don't hey
hey i don't like how long it took
everybody to realize that
i just didn't know what he was saying
yeah i don't know what yeah
and the angle he's got it up i didn't
see it and then that's the that's just
that's the logo nobody knows why but
they do know why that right there pistol
you know you know what the problem is
you're assuming all short guys have big
dicks but they wanna that that's that's
a good that's a well kept secret they
want people to short guys have huge
dongs but then the asian guys go in the
store like yeah
tell people god gave me length not
height that's right there you go i like
that yeah a lot of a lot of short guys
have they've done studies
they have right yep yeah there are a lot
of medical studies and everything about
medicine go ahead this out of your hold
it down average dick
you won't let me see your dick every
time i try to get hides it everything he
goes in the stall [ __ ] covers up with
his shoulder i'm like let me just get
one little peek
leave him alone let me see it
let's say you didn't grow up in the
locker room oh [ __ ] i know
yep
oh good luck find that key too short
guys have big penis system all because
no short guys have both a big and small
penis yeah i'm sure it just depends yeah
yeah chapelle's weird with his dick huh
yeah
when i was in college as a kid who
refused to take his towel off where like
something's going on sure enough he had
the biggest anteater you've ever seen oh
he did oh but no it wasn't i'm saying
like the hood yeah like it was like okay
like when my son puts on my jacket it
was like his arm with my hood
yeah yeah and that's why he was hiding
it
a lot of yeah all all skin no trunk yeah
well that's does he grow into the trunk
no he's 20 something years old he might
have no like is he a grower rather than
a shower
i don't know but either way he was very
ashamed of it
what else you got jen
here we go this came out last week will
smith is coming out with a book and he's
been releasing little snippets from his
memoir i liked will smith better when i
didn't know all this [ __ ] that's the
thing a lot of people are saying people
are saying that they liked jaden pickett
smith and will smith a lot more before
they started being yeah jada's like we
don't like to [ __ ] each other we have an
open relationship it's like oh you guys
are weird as [ __ ] what happened to the
cool will smith and will's like yeah i
was suicidal i'm thinking about killing
my dad it's like whoa fresh prince say
less dude
this is uh what
made way around the internet my father
was violent but he also had every game
plan game play recital he was an
alcoholic but he was sober at every
premiere of every movie
he listened every record okay sounds
like a solid guy likes to drink when i
was nine years old i watched my father
punch my mother inside of her head so
hard that she collabs saw her spit blood
they all right he divorced when uh was a
teen in 2000 was he a team look he loved
his son but he had the lowest point of
the relationship between smith and his
father came when he was caring for his
uh father into the end of his life one
night as i deadly wheeled him from his
bedroom toward the bathroom when
darkness rose with me the path between
the two rooms goes past the top of the
stairs all right as a child always told
myself that i would one day avenge my
mother
i pause at the top of stairs i punch him
right inside of his head just kidding
i could shove him down easy get away
with it as the decades of pain anger
resentment of course every day i shook
my head and proceeded to wheel daddy out
to the bathroom now is he doing sell
books you think
because i don't oh i know i'm not buying
it these are my eyes right now and i'm
underwater
i got skeptical hippo eyes yeah yeah
i don't believe anything like scottie
pippen
calling homeboy racist like all right
dude it's just a lot of this stuff
becomes
although sammy the book ravano talked
about his mother he loved his mother so
much and he literally says and at one
point i just thought you know she's in
so much pain and i thought about pushing
her down the steps and i think it would
have been boom boom boom boom boom and
that would have been painful but at the
end it would have been peace and i i
couldn't do it but i thought about it
but he's also a straight-up yeah he's a
killer he's also killed he says fresh
prince of bel-air yeah yeah
now is he doing this to become more
relatable which i'm all good dude i like
the view is the higher goodness i like
to view you're a better person than the
rest of us yeah
and and you know he also said he had
suicidal thoughts or something like that
too yeah he also talked about how he had
once considered suicide and he re
another thing came out about him being
really upset that he
uh had
jaden smith in the movie after earth and
it bombed and then that took a hit to
jaden's career shortly while he was a
teen then he asked to be emancipated
it's just a lot of like little family
things oh [ __ ] yeah heavy heavy drama
coming out
yeah he's had a pretty good life yep yep
still can't believe he's been famous
since he was 14 forever yeah forever and
uh and yeah and so
i'm sure that's why i like sure he came
with its struggles that's why i like
leonardo dicaprio he's not out there
he's not like oh i was sad the other
week no professional dude yes and by the
way it keeps that small tight group of
friends around him that's always had
those friends who are loyal to the core
he makes his climate videos
yeah when we talk about saving the world
but nobody's yeah he's not he's not
trying to [ __ ] oh you're talking
about this yeah it's like dude what are
you doing i think i can climb
up global warming dude i mean i i think
i could say this like after he did uh
titanic
he realized like my friend was with him
and he started to cry you know and he
said what's wrong he goes i don't want
to be i don't want to be this movie star
thing i don't want this to ruin me i
don't want to be this heartthrob teen
movie star so he [ __ ]
met with martin scorsese this is true
and scorsese said you got a friend
writing a book
no no okay
they were real close and he goes and he
goes um
you got to decide whether you want to be
an actor
and or you want to go for popularity and
that's why dicaprio linked up with a guy
named martin scorsese and if you look at
the movies the choices he made and how
he stayed the [ __ ] out of his life
that's what he started doing yeah like
that was a deliberate
move on his part because they wanted him
to be everything right
the new batman the new all this stuff
and he was like
yeah he was like no no i'm not doing
that yeah i'm not doing that i'm gonna
create some stuff you know
he's a great [ __ ] actor he's such a
beast
elon musk the other day went on twitter
and put up a poll saying i don't get
this roast do you see him roast the guy
who was making fun of him no oh really i
can't believe this article some guys
make was making fun of me said your
avatar looks uh like you just pee peed
it's like a weird like andrealovsky joke
thing it's weird
bring that up chin yeah this guy like
some guy was talking [ __ ] about him he
responded back about his avatar saying
he looks like peepee it was a weird
roast
um someone
he's a little bit on the spectrum yeah
oh yeah yeah
high high function yes
what christian just
say what you need to say see
people are maddie tweeted a penis joke
it's an old one though
no that's not it go out of here
all right
um
chinese poem about beans
no
it was a bad joke
i didn't get it
do you think it'd be on his twitter
right now
unless he got unless he got pulled down
62 million followers
yeah he's pretty famous
so it's probably gonna be here to oh
keep going
okay humankind
i don't see it on there maybe it was a
response to that guy
doesn't matter
yeah all right
well elon musk put up a poll on twitter
saying that if
more people voted yes rather than know
he would
go and sell 10 of his tesla stock in
order then to get taxed
in order to what to uh
uh pay the tax that people are
complaining that he doesn't pay
because he's saying that he doesn't get
a salary from tesla he gets uh money
based off of these stocks and so the
only way he would have to pay taxes is
if he sells his stocks
and so right now it is at 57 percent so
he might be
paying 25 million billion dollars worth
of taxes soon because of this twitter
poll wait
20 no he'll sell 25 billion dollars with
stock i don't think he's paying 25
billion oh okay there we go yeah
interesting
yeah i mean he has so much money selling
25 billion no that's nothing to him
worth of shares yeah he's like what
jesus is going to give a [ __ ]
worth a trillion dollars it's a thousand
million a trillion dollars a million
that's 25 000 million dollars
that's all the money 25 i mean i have 25
000 million so if you stack you stack a
million dollars you have 25 000 stacks
you walk in there's why are there 25 how
many stacks there are 25 000 stacks here
that's my money that's that's that's 10
of my money that's that's 10 of my money
what the [ __ ] are you talking about oh
it's jeff bezos i'll take one of those
stacks so speaking of leonardo dicaprio
there is a clip of leonardo dicaprio
jeff bezos and his girlfriend at the art
gala in la i believe it was at lacma
this past weekend and just look at his
girlfriend just swooning over leonardo
dicaprio
now is leo six foot eight or what's
going on
i think downstairs he's on stairs yeah
people just think that it's hilarious
how could you not though that you could
have all the money in the world and
leonardo leonardo dicaprio will still
steal your girlfriend i'll get jeff
basically
come on well it's just the way she's
looking the way she's waking up at home
she's a she's a bad evening
she's gorgeous yeah very strong [ __ ] me
eyes
yeah how could you not though she's very
hot
[Laughter]
oh you can't blame her
what you got jim all right let's see
oh vin diesel yeah hey he just posted
this
my little brother dwayne the time has
come the world awaits the uh dwayne's
like get out of here my little brother
as you know what my children refer to
you as uncle dwayne in my house there's
not a holiday that goes by
that day and you don't send well wishes
but the time has come legacy waits i
told you years ago that i was going to
film my promise to pablo
okay um i say this out of love but you
must show up do not leave the franchise
at all you have a very important role to
play
oh wow
so he's like putting pressure on him to
do the role because he said he'd never
work with him again
they had they had beef right yeah
why
i guess ben like runs a weird set and
was like like basically roxanne was like
super like uh immature like
unprofessional you know what i do with
that i'd be like cool uh i think the
world can live without another
fascination
i think the world can live with another
not we don't need any other
[Music]
you know what i do i say yes i go
absolutely i'll be right there so i was
gonna say you never show up i just
wouldn't say anything so how many diesel
came to you right now brian you say no
he's not the rock i i need money
yeah
dude i need money he's not dwayne the
rock johnson bro
you were playing as if you were twins i
had you guys to be i'd be all up in that
i'd be able to do that i'd be jumping
out of the helicopter
whatever you need yeah i got your
brother if i'm the rock and i look at my
schedule my god this ain't happening
apparently a guy was fishing with his
buddies
and so he they were getting attacked by
bees so they jumped in the water
and then they found this guy eaten by
piranhas later on the other two guys
exactly
that's not fake it's not fake but the as
far as piranhas killing him there's like
very i don't know there's not that no
there's nothing
like in movies now you jump in and
pronounce it yeah and you do the bone
so he was in pieces but they believed
that he drowned
in the process
either way it sucks for this dude big
time then he got eaten yeah
bees
yeah it's
disfigured by the pronouns jesus christ
so he was all [ __ ] up from b so he
jumped into piranha yeah i'm sure you
guys are probably jumping in the water
too right if you were getting attacked
by that we take a look before we're in
bristol yeah yeah brazil i see a bunch
of piranhas like i'm gonna deal with
these bees
over a crocodile yeah or hippos yeah
yeah that's my i'm not doing it mine
goes they're crocodiles
africa you don't wanna you know i think
that's africa brazil brazil well brazil
doesn't have uh saltwater crocodiles i
don't believe i think you're okay right
i don't think you does brazil have
saltwater carpet yeah i don't think i
don't know see don't type saltwater see
if they have crocodiles say man eating
crocodiles
crocodiles dude
crocodiles they do but those are caimans
approximately 10 million 10 million yeah
but those are caimans but oh it's the
largest crocodilian population on earth
yeah but they're not ones that
eat you i've never met a nice alligator
yeah like look let's see are there
alligators yeah
oh wow you're putting that in humans
wow that's a weird all right
all right i don't want to eat a zebra
all right let's do
the other caymans either way and if it's
a big one you don't want to jump in that
water yeah i don't think that's what you
have to worry about that can't be good
though dude yeah
yeah it's not salty though are you guys
with khalifa fans at all sure sure yeah
taylor getting what's good
i mean taylor grant black and yellow
black and yellow yeah he's obviously
very very popular and people love his
music i just never for whatever reason i
couldn't figure out his style whatever
it just doesn't resonate with me so
anyways he did the theme song for pfl
which is a
a fighting promotion he's a promotion
he's the owner and part owner and pfl
i'll just play it for a little bit just
you guys can get a feel of it he's a
great performer
[Music]
does he have to be boxing you yeah
well he does train let's
[Music]
they should just promote kamala harrison
that's it just show her the whole okay
look here
what is this for the pfl it's the theme
song for pfl it's pretty good
it's a good it's a good he's you like it
really yeah i like it oh wow i don't
like those i don't know you're a big
you're big whiskey i like his voice
i wouldn't like his album like him when
he's featured on other songs i don't
like he's got a good voice i don't i
don't know anything he's cool oh it's a
little cheesy tall i see what you're
thinking
i see what you're thinking he's
definitely not six eight but i see what
you're thinking
is he six four let's see i think he
might be seven feet i think he's seven
eight six four yeah six four damn
you're six four yeah yeah he's tall and
skinny
insurance that he thought he was gay
when he was growing up
as a boy because he's so feminine guys
man what and he has album coming out
right here albums just dropped that i
don't know but hey i need to start
selling tickets you're going to get some
weird [ __ ] out of me
business starts failing
i'm gonna start dropping some gems say
you think you're gay growing up what
does that that that would usually mean i
am excited to study like dudes men when
they take their shirt off yeah like i
want i see guys and i want to [ __ ] them
like that's what i would consider where
you'd be confused would he confusing
that with like he was into like art and
stuff he's had a very feminine side and
yeah he doesn't really like the boyish
kind of things like football beer that
kind of stuff at least back then oh okay
neil does crystal yeah
yeah i mean chris doesn't like sports
nothing
it's very yeah he like musical theater
ain't nothing wrong with that yeah yeah
but i mean i don't know to say that you
actually thought you might be hardest
kind of makes me feel like maybe there
was something there but i don't know
no i mean i like in other words when
you're a kid you're like wait i'm not
into these things maybe i'm gay like you
don't you're kids you don't have a
couple well if you're like yeah i'm way
too into [ __ ]
theater man there's a lot of gays
involved in theater theater and dong you
know theater and dong what i'm saying
he's like weird man like dick in theater
yeah why is only the only thing in my
head is theater and dog yeah i didn't
know calpin yeah i just found that out
too
did he just come out
harold and kumar
indeed oh wow really interesting you
don't believe it
i wouldn't bat my eyes if he came out i
was like hey i realize i can fly
i wouldn't care
[Music]
okay
i agree so many people coming out with
see is he going over the books yeah
he's coming out with a memoir there you
go
yeah
and he was under obama's administration
for a while too he's super smart yeah
bye
yeah he came out you gained all right
cool man they became i was like yeah man
i can grow wings i'm like right what
else you got jen
it's funny how it makes news and
nowadays like yeah yeah
publicist right and they're getting out
sell books and [ __ ]
so this kid had brain cancer and tom
brady sent them a message he said that
if tom brady thinks i can beat brain
cancer then i can then he beat bring
cancer oh
chris godwin
i know right
behind the bench you know there's a
little boy you know look look over so i
kind of caught a glimpse and then saw
his dad and his dad said he started
crying noah you made a video for him
earlier this year so i didn't know he
was actually at the game
yeah i'm like in shock i like don't
really believe it's happening he sticks
a hat on my head he shakes my hand and
he says
he says something like
nice job buddy
[Music]
it's hellish to go through that [ __ ] i
can imagine cancer is not a good thing
not a good thing
he's emotional tom brady is emotional
you ever hear him talking about his dad
he's just
dead yeah or his kids man yeah yeah
i love it he said he started crying
about hey elephant room that mom was
smoking
i thought someone was gonna want
somebody to cry that mama's want to
change the subject before we all start
crying that mom was smoke shot
i uh tom brady talks about how he didn't
make like after the combines or
something he didn't get drafted or he
did he was like six rounds he said he
said yeah but they didn't they were
waiting and he said we went for a walk
and he starts crying that was a tough
day yeah just remembering that
he's so part of maybe his greatness is
how emotionally is how much he cares you
know jordan's the same way he [ __ ]
still takes that [ __ ] seriously he still
remembers his losses oh yeah
what does he get jen all right last one
do you guys know who mr beast is
he's a huge youtube guy i don't know who
he is
um so he's a really famous youtube guy
that he yeah he gets they tried money
awesome too and they they couldn't what
did he do
nothing they were just trying to like
come up with this
i think that taylor lorenz or some some
he said i wish the 456 contestants good
luck next week yeah so he's building uh
like a squid game set holy [ __ ] yeah it
actually already happened i think logan
paul came out and uh like spoiled a part
of it because logan paul was a part of
this holy [ __ ] he got a bunch of
youtubers to play for i think a few
million dollars that's amazing holy [ __ ]
this guy spends millions of dollars uh
every single video because he's in the
back yeah
he says it's all just for tax write-offs
at this point yeah wow that is yeah he
went he is one of the biggest creators
that's a straight up where's this
where's this special guy i'm not sure
what's going to say he's a special dude
man oh i bet the content he's going to
get out of it's going to be nuts
that's so cool i don't know how many
people died
hey come on
god
squid game
why they called squid game
because because the very last game is
squidward he played squid as a kid right
squid game hey bro
that's the entire nature of the show
the very first episode of another video
yeah i remember
i didn't see it they were playing funny
i was like i didn't see them
do it and then he'll be and then brian
will be do you remember uh when they're
playing marbles i didn't really play
marbles as a kid i'd be kind of [ __ ]
that was the one game i'm like i didn't
really play
marvel is it like like well the marble
ones uh was the game where they could
make it up i know but let's say you
partner with somebody who played marbles
you'd like i don't know well you can
make up your own marvel okay
i thought you like shoot them at like
each other like the marvels like you
like there's all sorts of games but if
you like someone actually played like
legit marbles but yeah i'm [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] but then you'd have to agree to
play the game before we both die
true you could do stuff too like i
remember playing marbles when i was
younger so you take a marble like this
with your your middle finger you could
smack someone's marble throw that away
that's a point or something like that
and then yeah i'm not i'm not putting my
life on so it's like pogs [ __ ] that i'm
not sure if it's like pogba yeah ooh
it's actually it got pretty like legit
people knew what they're doing from far
away too about that tug of war thing
when the old guy was like i used to play
a lot as a kid we have to leave a whole
game plan [ __ ]
i was dope he was
amazing yeah
how about the one rich gay guy like take
off your mess terrible acting though
why would that happen okay that's what i
wanted to talk about acting and they
made the americans seem all stupid it
was so weird he was like i'll take that
guy
just the white people though just the
rich but the white spoiler alert the
rich people but i wonder i would do
wonder did they do that on purpose
yeah to make
koreans look not i'm not saying that no
we do but we we've historically done it
to asians in our movies yeah like we
make them make them so they're probably
like [ __ ] these but also asians might
have been casting it and because the
english was their second language
koreans were like these guys it's hard
to tell in korean dramas i used to watch
dramas they would hire like just rookie
actors for american people yeah so i'd
rather have an asian guy in white face
you know what i'm saying like give
somebody probably get actors because
everybody's like what is this yeah
you'll find some older white guys to do
it yeah but dude i'd rather him go
korean white face
and then use subtitles
so it's more organic
those white guys were awful
i'll take 69. there was an asian guy too
though right there was like one rich
asian guy that was part of the crew
he barely taught he barely talked yeah
yeah but yeah they made him look so dumb
and then the acting was terrible on that
part i told my girlfriend yeah i'm like
how bad are these i know
jesus kind of bummed me out it was so
good up until then he was like if you
can finish me off in less than five
minutes like holy [ __ ] this guy's gay
he's aggressive yeah
he's coming out with a book too yep he's
coming out with a book
this weekend dallas
dallas texas thursday friday saturday
one show thursday filming friday and
saturday only those shows are damn near
sold out then that's this week so let's
ride uh november 27th everett washington
one night one show only in the theater
and ever at washington found out ever is
about 30 minutes outside seattle come on
out and then just announce
bring in 2022 with your boy in the thick
boy squad at dania florida we'll find
out dania improv uh
dania improv dania dania dania improv in
florida that's december 30th through
january 1st really have you ever been
there no it's it's it's it's new it's
new club where is dania florida near
like not too far from miami or no it's
far from miami oh it is yeah i think it
you fly to fort lauderdale wow okay oh
it's broward county seminole hard rock
oh that's great you're gonna love it
that's where the old uh hard rock uh
that's where the fort lauderdale improv
was that's gonna be amazing might as
well be fort lauderdale right yeah yeah
it is it's gonna be because that's what
they pitched oh that's gonna be amazing
and then when dania brought it up i love
that you they just redid that yeah it's
brand new yeah yeah that's gonna be so
be fun for new year's right you're gonna
love it are you kidding i'm gonna
wrestle alligators you're gonna love it
i guarantee it's gonna be one of the
best shows you've ever done oh wow all
right but dallas this weekend shooting
the special let's go car hey let's go
brian hey hey um oh look it's in
blackness ohio god damn it no it's not
columbus ohio november 11th the 14th is
not columbus ohio it is
off the hook in naples florida there's
columbus i don't know we got to change
that so that's not the only thing i got
to connect you with my guy yes let me do
it off the hook comedy club november
11th to the 14th november 19th 20th
orlando florida november 17th to the
19th kansas city missouri let's go
boom
and then november 17th tacoma washington
november 18th spokane
washington december 1st
san jose
improv rockfin
uh conspiracy social club me and sam
tripoli rockfin dot com slash conspiracy
social club for all your conspiracy and
comedy needs boom and check out
chappelle's world yes
then haters will say with mark remark
harley's also out too go get em all
right guys love you we're out